hey what's up everybody hi hello
jake's here in person i forgot my guitar
i don't know how i got here but welcome
to the quarter digital podcast everybody
episode 138
wow i'm back yeah thank you so much for
uh your comments and uh your viewership
on oh i totally forgot
for so long
thank you so much for your comments and
your viewerships on the last episode uh
it uh
was really just a lot of i think it was
very cathartic for everybody and we felt
that uh we were we felt we would be
remiss if we did not bring ren on
to talk about this so he started it all
yes the man who started it all um is
here with us ren wykman we've also got
nico and mr dean
if you need to know anything
about any comic universe dean actually
creates the stories for the publishers
comes up with them all himself so um so
it's 1938 that's right yeah that's crazy
yeah he's actually a time traveler
meanwhile nico's literally playing
civilization right now
wow nico you really are selling how
interesting these podcasts started no
trust me this is good he's ready for ren
to rant because this is wren's platform
yeah let's be real i'm here to spice up
this monologue spice it up not to like
hype up i feel like i don't have
anything to say right now
i don't know nothing really happened to
eventful in the last week
except for you know
everything
except for lots of things okay so if you
haven't
listened to last week's podcast
uh
i was not in it but it was about
something that i said
it was basically
i got so fed up and furious about my
experience
that morning with adobe after effects
that i tweeted something incredibly out
of character for me yeah i i tweeted
something angry and i swore in it you
used bad words i used a bad word oh no
which yeah it's not something i ever
really do publicly it's not something i
intend it's not something i don't know i
don't did you just feel like that was
the only thing like with friends
did you just feel like that was it was a
call for help it was like a cry for like
witness me did you feel like it was
something like that for you or it was i
think a breaking point it was something
that i've been kind of feeling for quite
some time years at this point
all coalescing into a single moment
where i realized i'd had enough
it was the moment i slammed my hand onto
the table after trying a second computer
and was able to replicate the problem
there
listen i
i don't
i have had so many after effects crashes
over the years
or not okay i've had so many software
crashes over the years it's not a big
deal it's just part of the game
and
in this morning because i was trying to
finish up
my our satisfying render i had already
rendered
i'll just do this
basically the
the second half of my second render
which was a better simulation
didn't really work and so i was like all
right i'm just going to take my first
render and do a mask transition on to
the second render at the in at the end
of it just a simple mask a animated
keyframed mask and it kept causing after
effects to literally blip out of
existence
just like no crash no freezing i was
just like i would do something and it
would just like it was as if i minimized
it to the to the tray
and i would quit even faster when you
actually quit the program it actually
kind of created a situation where i was
efficiently crashing it over and over
again
i went into problem solving mode for two
straight hours
i'm not exaggerating when i say after
effects crashed on me over 100 times in
a two-hour span is there a superhero
that has this power dean are you that
you're familiar with i well i will say
the blip like when it just when the
window disappears rather than
it's just you know it starts like you
know just slowing down you just hit
those three buttons and like made them
all made them all go into the sub bar
yeah but like
i just want to say the blip is
less frustrating i i'd say well not a
hundred times but the blip versus like
the i'm clicking like i'm smashing my
mouse and it's like the screen because
then that's wasting time at least when
it blipped away i was able to instantly
start after effects back up and start
trying so it created the situation where
i was able to explore a whole host of
different possible solutions listen i'm
a seasoned
crashing software problem solver at this
point i was i cleared my cache i
restarted the computer i was basically i
had re-rendered
my render itself into different formats
and imported that back in i i deleted
keyframes and restarted from scratch it
was because it was always happening on
the same frame no sometimes it was
different frames but usually on this one
frame and i was trying to like
all this different stuff i went to after
effects 2021
2019 previous versions uh which requires
you to like have to save out a certain
type of older file to be compatible with
the older software like
trust me when i say that i did all of
the things i could possibly think of
to fix it and the thing that ended up
fixing a simple effect i'm literally
just animating a mask
with with a feather and also a variable
feather that's the only like complicated
thing i can imagine for it
um
and the thing that ended up fixing it
was i added an additional mask
on top of it so i didn't have to animate
the keyframe it was it's stupid it
doesn't matter the point was that i
reached
a boiling point where i just got fed up
i had to walk outside and get some air
and i realized in that moment that
everything that i've been feeling up
until this point which is that after
effects is old and decrepit
was true
and well not just after effects yes it's
it's
it's part
it's a symptom of a lot of
things that has that have happened to
the adobe suite you know you were
complaining a lot about premiere
ironically i've not really had that many
problems with premiere
um well jonah just last night was here
for an extra two hours just trying to
export and of course he had to join
getting to resolve he had he said he's
he said he's
this is what happened
it's like if you know premiere you know
resolve like
it's not hard to switch you had a very
basic problem too though it was
something like with his motion graphics
and he had to like oh yeah re-export the
motion graphics separately and then
bring them back in essential graphics
was always an issue for us and like
you know for us with premiere we worked
on premiere for years and then last year
we switched over to resolve
and
i mean
that years ago i was having these like
critical issues like uh i don't know
people remember that andrew the first
episode andrew kramer was on on vfx arts
react
uh nick and i were here until 2 a.m and
we ended up
screen capping the entire episode in
premiere we tried everything like and i
was able to render out the entire
timeline play through it fine couldn't
couldn't export it and you couldn't even
do the thing where it's like all right
this is a cached file somewhere that you
can actually open and access it's some
crazy like mpeg file
type yeah you couldn't even do that no
and so we just these those kind of bugs
that also happen so often that we have a
protocol for it that's not the first
time we had to screen cap now yeah your
timeline i've yeah
there's been multiple i think there's
been another episode and stuff i've done
where i've just had to screen cap it out
of premiere which is like it's just
ridiculous to think that we have videos
on youtubes that are that's literally
screen caps yeah like the episodes that
we had but you know what
i can forgive
crashing programs it sucks especially in
a professional environment where you
need reliability and a robust program
but
i think the thing that adds to it for me
is just the overall feeling that
the software feels old you know like i
don't want to have to like well it might
be worth backing up and like starting
the story a little bit more from the
beginning i think one of the reasons why
you're upset or why you're also like
well it hurts like you said the software
is old but
like we grew up on after effects
i started learning how we learned via
effects through after effects you know
yeah no exactly i started learning how
to do visual effects
uh true visual effects not like this
clone cropping stuff in a video timeline
and it was like beginning of 2009 i
discovered videocopilot.net and i was
using cs3
what after effects cs3 and creamer here
the crazy thing is that if you're to
look at the user interface of cs3
compared to 2022
apart from like high resolution text and
like
slightly different colors you've got
those
so they got that well it's the exact
same as what i'm trying to say the
overall user experience is exactly the
same
for the last
couple decades
i
or at least it's like
13 years yeah it's like you guys be like
we nailed it guys we nailed it the first
time digital video barely even a thing
yet but this interface it's perfect you
never have to change it
so like like dean was saying everyone
started transitioning over to davinci
resolve last year for editing
but
i kind of like stood my ground i was
like that's cute that's nice i'm going
to stick with premiere because i know
how to use premiere granted premiere and
resolve they're both editing programs
it's the same same stuff you put video
on a timeline you chop it up it's the
same principles in final cut pro avid
premiere
uh
friggin lumafusion whatever and
movie maker uh yeah imovie
windows movie yeah exactly it's just
that one program actually uses your gpu
yeah and the other one does so after
effects and and premiere have certain
effects that will use your gpu right it
has
honest honestly it has very good uh red
reading like red footage works really
well in premiere
which is why like we were having this
discussion earlier with jonah he was
talking about how he loves the the proxy
system in premiere
and i was just like i've never used
proxy proxies and also resolved
literally i've never used proxy results
make makes proxies very easy because
yeah like back in the day when we would
shoot like those corridor short films we
would shoot them all at 5k or 4k 6k
whatever and we would just have the
native raw files in the timeline
max compression which on the red still
looks better than anything else yeah
youtube ruins it anyway man
you can't tell me you can tell the
difference between 720 and 4k on youtube
i mean i can tell the difference
barely
it's harder to tell the difference
between 1080 and 4k yes it's super hard
to tell the difference between 4k
literally impossible to tell the
difference between 4k and 8k yeah our
eyes literally just don't have the
acuity to like but it's not even the
number of pic it's not even the
resolution it's the compression of the
footage on youtube it gets compressed in
the camera and then it gets compressed
again when it gets uploaded yeah but
yeah like kendrick lamar just put out
his new music video and um
it's one shot on a dark red background
and you just see these big blocks
yeah well that's i think yeah yeah
that's that's due to the the bit depth
and
bad compression
yeah so if you're watching these on
quarter digital.com you're gonna get way
better compression just just a note it's
ironic because like a static background
with this type of compression should
look better because the pixels aren't
changing from frame to frame so they
should be the highest quality but it's
that sort of like gradation of like a a
gray to a darker gray that you end up
with that stair-stepping
banding effect
anyway what was that where was i getting
that after effects
but yeah like it was our old love it was
the thing we started on but here's the
thing are we just teenagers experiencing
this part where you fight with your
parents because you're growing up
like is after effects just are we just
first cut is the deep
i was definitely
because i've i have a friend who teaches
nuke he's worked in the industry for
years and every time we hang out he
tries to convince me to get onto that
nuke train
and and then we hired fenner who is a
nuke master and
converted
jordan into a nuke trainee and he's now
blasting away and i'm just seeing the
stuff they're doing i'm like man
maybe it's time i get in the nuke but
you know really what it comes down to is
i it's time to get into a node-based
compositing workflow and you know what
else has that davinci resolution
technically it's called fusion but it's
inside this same program and here's okay
i have one complaint about davinci
resolve that i'll bring up when i have
some complaints too oh okay there's
something that you omitted from the
previous podcast about a bad experience
with resolve where a lot of work was
lost
um but
the reason why i'm mentioning after
effects and premiere just kind of
feeling old is that
resolved feels new it's it's a newer
program it was i mean the program itself
might be older i first learned resolve
in 2014 for color grading
and it was like the thing that you would
kick out a render from premiere and
important to resolve to color grade and
that was when i started learning like
the node based coloring system and all
that stuff with uh that was how we
originally used it was just color suite
but like now it's like it was a 25 000
software
before it was like free
that's the thing it's one piece of
software that dynamically connects all
the different facets of it it's you got
the fair light for audio you have fusion
for compositing and it's all very
capable and then all each one of those
has extraordinary depth yeah yeah and
well they're dedicated
but it's so much more than just features
you know i feel like adobe is always
adding features to their software but
it's just it's like putting on more
stuff on a pile more makeup but like the
foundation is just so old that it
doesn't feel sturdy you know yeah after
effects doesn't when i
cannot export
an h.264
file directly out of after effects
because
i have to send it to media encoder which
is the worst program on the entire
planet yeah which never works it's like
why do you want to wait 45 seconds for
this other person no that's quick
i have a bunch of plugins and all those
plugins have to then open again inside
this separate program which is going to
eat up even more of your ram
and and that's just so that media
encoder can open the idea of media
encoder is great you can continue
working after effects while your
video is rendering
but it
these steps
they they're adding additional steps and
when those steps go from taking half a
second to taking minutes
it it's it's garbage yeah and and
when premiere first had like the dynamic
link by being able to send stuff to
after effects that was like the one
thing that kept me as an adobe user for
so long and i didn't even use it the way
they intended yeah none of us do i never
actually used the dynamic links
it was i would send it to after effects
so to create a project file with my raw
red footage with the correct in and out
points and the correct resolution of the
composition and then i would go back to
premiere and hit undo yeah so that i
could get rid of that dynamically linked
like yeah file now because it gets rid
of the original file otherwise it
renders yeah it really gets rid of your
raw clip who wants to do that just put
the copy above come on guys i told them
that in person one time to be clear
we've had conversations with developers
from adobe we've been to like their
adobe meetups in vegas at nab and i've
literally talked to one of the lead
developers and i've requested that like
please don't just replace it just like
maybe add it he's like well you could
just like alt drag it up and then do it
on that layer i'm like
yes you just added more right
i guess i can do that
but no you just add more steps exactly
that's my point it's it's that mentality
well i think it's because they they're
like but that's what we want you to use
dynamic link that way but it never works
that way right yeah cause why would you
want to render an after effects
file in your premiere timeline
in real time it doesn't work in real
time after effects is not a real-time
program it's like yeah you can cache it
but their cache system is so fragile
it's like you move it a little bit and
then it's like oh there goes the cache
yeah and it's like again in theory
it's amazing you know it's like being
able to if you have a
a sequence of shots and you can just
like do all the work in after effects
then go back to your premiere timeline
and hit you know export and everything
renders all at once like in theory
that's
that's great but in in practice
again it's like
an old man with a cane trying to like do
the 400 meter relay and
adobe
there's too many points of failure you
know nico you know what's real cool is
when you're in resolve and you know
you're editing and you just you just
click over to the fusion page and
suddenly your layer is now a fusion clip
yeah that's just really cool so great
they have this like ai based depth mat
that you can just generate it's almost
like you give it a couple seconds and it
kicks and you just hit the spacebar and
it plays and you do crazy things like
you know how after effects made a big
deal about roto brush too but that's
literally just a side feature in the
color page on on resolve that's
oh man do they have ai based uh slow
motion in davinci resolve oh yeah
yeah it's it's like any like we we used
to shoot all the crew videos in like uh
60 frames per second so we could slow
everything down you know if i just
dedicate it slow it down well you know
you guys haven't heard of aces they
actually have full aces support davinci
resolve oh yeah it's great it's really
easy it's just like a drop down i mean i
i had to install a whole like ocio thing
in after effects to get that working and
it still like
didn't work that's uh not quite working
for you there i'm of course like i'm
dunking hard on after effects but that's
because i'm just so so angry and
i don't know it's
i'm so i made that tweet and it it went
like kind of viral it was like low-key
viral you know i was like that's so loki
i got a lot of responses of basically uh
thoughts that echoed my thinking yeah a
lot of people agreed with the sentiment
and i don't want to just podcast
comments are the same yeah and a lot of
people have the same experience we have
and we're recording this pretty much
right after
the first podcast went live and we've
already heard back from adobe like it
caught their attention and so i'm not
going to comment any further on that
because that's hopefully going to become
an ongoing conversation i would love if
they like
took our
our
suggestions all right wren you're in
charge of adobe oh boy fix after effects
what do you do
fix premiere fix whatever you want jump
in what do you do so you've unlimited
everything
it's not worth it
it's important to note that what i said
was essentially after effects needs to
be rewritten from the ground up like
get rid of it rewrite something from
scratch that brings in new thinking new
innovative ideas
and
new
efficient ways to work with modern
hardware that just feels modern like we
have unreal engine literally rendering
incredibly intense scenes in real time
and after effects is like oh this shape
layer is going to take
0.1 fps
to render
and and stuff like that and so
my suggestion was to completely restart
it but i thought about that more because
i was talking with uh stu mashowitz
from red giant who is an old industry
vet not that he's old but he's been in
the industry for a while
and and he says he he's
he knows too much about software
engineering to
think about suggesting a complete
rewrite
and so that made me start thinking about
it
ditch after effects
make something new make a new
node-based program that is an actual
competitor to fusion to nuke
to these programs and keep after effects
around as like a legacy program people
can continue using it if they want but
there's this new program that does
compositing with node-based stuff i
think
i'll just say i think what makes after
effects special is that it's not
node-based it's the layer base i agree
yeah which is why i'm like i really just
want there's no base tools out there but
there isn't a layer based tool like
after effects yeah and that's what i was
going to say is like you guys myself
everybody upstairs we all learned from
andrew kramer video co-pilot
and because layer based is just easier
to understand than node-based it's more
intuitive because you start you start in
premiere or final cut and you're like
okay i put a video clip next to the next
video clip and then i can put one over
it and turn the opacity down
after effects is like
the next step from there yeah that's
really old film visual effects it's
layer based compositing yeah and so is
it still like i think it's still like
nico's saying i think it's still worth
it for people who are
um hobbyists um
young filmmakers you know like i think
it
there's immense depth to it but it does
have a ceiling of
like you always talk about ren where
it's just it gets so complicated so fast
when you try to do complex things and
it's but it's like it's still possible
you know like i've done some of the most
incredibly complex shots before all in
after effects it's like it's just
because it's possible doesn't mean it's
the right tool for the job yeah you know
i used to edit all of my videos in after
effects oh and what else timeline-based
editing and sound design what else did
you do in after effects you did sound
design and ae yeah don't you use after
effects as your photo oh yeah
photoshop i do all of my photoshopping
in
yeah these after effects of the
thumbnails for now
yeah that's i i did too
all of my thumbnails all of my images
they're all edited in after effects
after effects is just photoshopped with
motion exactly exactly it's video
photoshop yeah video shop yeah but you
know
like
it's the tricky thing with a program
like that there's a million different
people using it a million different ways
and so like what we need isn't
necessarily what other people need so
like that's where like
as like a line of communication opens up
between us and adobe and they're like so
so what's up it's like i'm careful
because it's like i don't want to just
say what i need because that's not
reflective necessarily what everybody
needs yeah they have to like kind of
follow the least common denominator to a
certain degree different degree well
yeah they've done that we can all agree
that the program
i think we can all agree that
i guess what you're saying when you say
we're at the program it's like
step back and what is what is after
effects supposed to do
not crash that's first yes first it's
not crash like what what tools does it
serve
and then build it from the ground up
with a new interface in mind that
minimizes your clicks
it minimizes things that you don't need
to mess with it does things
automatically that otherwise you are
always doing like
just have it figure it out and save me
time it's a tool right so if like if you
if you had to push eight buttons to turn
on your car every day it's like boy i
wish somebody would just invent a car
just had to push one button because i'd
have to just push the same eight buttons
every day and now our cars we just get
in and drive away there's no on button
no i'm button and that's kind of like
what after effects is like i still sit
down i have to push the same buttons to
turn it on it's like
why don't why is it just one button yet
like you know i do this so many times
and so many other people must do at the
same time i saw a presentation for a
program called autographs wait nico they
have that it's called nesting
i saw i saw a presentation for a program
called autograph which uh a dev team is
working on i think they might be french
and it's like it's basically a straight
up a hey we think we can make after
effects but we can make it what it
should be oh so it's layer based it's
layer based it has a node based version
also side by side running the same thing
whoa so you can switch back and forth
yes i believe i believe i hope i'm not
i'm not sure how that's going to work
but that would be nice but here's what's
special it's all hyper real time so you
drop paper real time type of real time
is it like real drop in your footage you
can hit play while your footage is
playing you can change your composition
settings you can change your like oh i
want my resolution to be this my
favorite this and the video it's just
playing you can move it around you can
add layers you can mask it it's all
playing in real time they have a really
nice like hey you click on the video
rather than having a tiny pixel and then
tiny pixel wide lines sticking out for
your handles and you're moving gizmo
it's like here's all the different
things you need like squish stretch
scale move translate corner pin with
nice easy to big easy big to click on
icons like all right there in front of
you like you know thought through and
made handy
and once again it's just all real time
pull the key do a you know do a masking
thing on the edge and it's just like
it's it's like unreal engine you know
it's like unreal engine versus 3ds max
like one can do a billion polygons real
time on my screen with global
illumination and one requires me to
click 20 boxes before it even renders
its first ray traced image you know yeah
i'm i'm okay so there's a story i have
in after effects for the longest time
okay
so after effects has the rota brush tool
where you essentially paint brush
strokes and the tool intelligently
figures out where the edges you're
trying to rotoscope actually are so if
there's like a person or a car or a box
or whatever you just kind of do a green
brush stroke over it and suddenly you
have this mask that has appeared along
the edges of the thing and where it
isn't supposed to be you take a red
brush stroke across that and it dials it
back and it's kind of like a back and
forth sort of process on a frame by
frame basis but when you have hundreds
of frames that you're trying to get
through you're going through like frame
at a time maybe sometimes every other
frame and and you're looking at the
actual image and you're staring at it
and you're because you're trying to
to like study how it's moving
so you're almost kind of like
looking at it in an abstract way as
opposed to visually looking at something
like you would when you're reading and
what after effects would do is that you
would make a brush stroke and the entire
image would blink to black
for just like a half second sometimes
upwards of one or two seconds if if you
had a lot of keyframes or your shot was
really heavy and then it would come back
but the problem is that now that frame
is out of your visual cortex and you're
now looking at a new shot without that
sort of before and after
comparison like stored in the ram buffer
of your brain
and
it was just such a it would ruin your
flow and it was like it was so hard to
try to use rotobrush when that would
happen and i
it would get it got better in in in
iterations since then in versions of
after effects since then but it would
still happen it literally still happened
to me in after effects 2022 a couple
months ago i was trying to do roto-brush
stuff and it would blank to black and so
it was we were at nab 2019 i believe
maybe it's 2018 it was a few years ago
and i remember we had a conversation
with one of the lead developers on after
effects one of the product uh managers
and i remember asking him can is there
any way to fix that and he's like
[Music]
no
the the code that everything's built on
is too old we can't fix that
he said to my face that they cannot fix
that problem because it's too old time
to abandon it never forget that i don't
i don't even remember who the guy was i
do not remember his name i'm sorry to
anyone who might know who that was and
they're trying to figure it
out but i was just it's that type of
thinking that i'm frustrated by you know
i was like oh we can't do that this is
too old then
make it not old
but
they cannot hold
yes but here's the problem though that
adobe is facing because they have a
prime example of a company that took a
program and completely rewrote it from
scratch and then everyone hated it
final cut 10.
does everyone hate pocket10 they did
when it first came out but i feel like
they've come to come around there's a
whole i watched a whole amazing
documentary about it a friend of mine
actually edited it so
i forget the name of it god dang it well
actually you know what i
it was a huge controversy at the time it
and single-handedly why adobe premiere
started blowing up except apple didn't
make final cut pro 10 for pros
it wasn't it's imovie pro yeah it's
imovie
it's amazing imovie pro now it's legit
pro oh okay yeah well now it's now it's
okay the documentary was about how like
they they wanted to reapproach the
software and they did exactly what we're
describing they they apple literally did
that and then they put out this program
that they thought all right here's a new
fresh way of thinking about how you edit
all of these cool new features and it
was it was different and so everyone who
used final cut 7 hated it they weren't
able to do some of the same things
they'd always done before
and it took about two years of apple
constantly putting out new updates for
final cut 10 for people to finally be
like wait a minute this is actually
amazing there's like no man's sky
remember that game it's exactly like no
man's sky so adobe's gotta grit their
teeth and do that and they're gonna have
to go through two years of people
whining about it yeah because people
that's how people
are on the internet and
now that you have people who are like
final cut x final cut 10 is like the
best editing program out there they
wouldn't dream of using anything else
and i'm talking about like so many of
the top youtubers who are editing videos
and whatnot they're all doing it in
final cut 10 on freaking imax i feel
like laptops resolve is definitely
on the up and up though as more people
move to it i feel like they're putting
more resources into it and i think it's
it's quickly becoming like
i don't know
like the premiere
yeah yeah i guess what i'm trying to say
is that like maybe adobe is afraid of
that happening to them too
it's always a concern i'm sure it's
always and it's a reasonable concern
but now
but after fasting is awesome after
effects should play in real time when i
put a video clip my timeline hit the
spacebar
like when that's it when i just
literally put the video clip my time and
hit the spacebar that should play in
real time yeah the fact that it doesn't
it's like it still has to load it to
your cache some problems exist for so
long that you can't see them anymore and
that's one of those things it's like
where's the engineer at adobe who looks
at the program fresh and goes wait a
minute why do i have why am i accepting
that i have to sit here and wait for
this thing to take this long to open why
do i accept that i have to sit here and
wait for this thing to have to load the
a single video with no effects on it why
is that okay in 2022 you know yeah why
don't you have to watch it at quarter
quality yeah
like where's that mindset
you know where's that person working at
adobe and looking at after effects like
that
where's the person goes like okay i use
the program all the time this is the
thing i do all the time that takes me
eight clicks how can i make that one
click do you think where's that person
that they're working with artists who
are using the program yeah i do
yeah because i do because they they
communicate resources but i feel like it
is it's like ren saying where it's just
it's such an old program at this point
to build on top of it just
it's like you're just stack i mean it's
kind of like
uh
like the us's laws like we just keep
throwing more laws on top it's not like
okay let's break all this down let's
figure out from the ground up like what
we do no we used to just have one it was
called the constitution
and then we had to [ __ ] it all up yeah
and it's just over time i think it's
just anything it's like what is it the
law entropy or something like i mean
yeah it's and it's like again i
understand it i get it it's like you
have all of these
features that just kind of end up
bloating the stuff up and then they have
to go through and create a new feature a
new optimization that takes like this
chunk of the pile and makes it like
smaller but it's still
standing upon the foundation of a large
ass pile
yeah
i think freddy said it best in response
to caroline on that tweet where it's
like i'm sorry you're doing your best
and she did she's a warrior respect but
like
you know that's not going to accommodate
the fact that that there's like decades
of technical debts yeah it's technical
debt that's exactly what it is and scott
and i talk about this and we go over
that on the
site too and it's
it's a real thing like you have to be on
top of that because
you'll go oh well we're just gonna quick
do this or we're just gonna quick do
that and then
like time goes by or something takes off
and
and then you don't come back to the very
basic things that just aren't working
that that need to be working um how
would you define technical debt
it's
i mean at least in my experience it's
basically just glitches it's like little
simple things where it's like oh yeah i
know that's a glitch but if you just do
this thing that you shouldn't have to do
then it works
yeah i would call them bandages like
yeah
shortcuts
where you you're making something and
you instead of creating a really robust
system like whatever that little thing
is instead of creating a robust system
you're like
it's close enough i'm gonna hack the
last ten percent together yep and those
ten percent hacks accumulate over time
that is the debt that's is exactly it
that's exactly you gotta pay your dues i
feel like that was steve jobs whole
i think that's why people
look fondly back on steve jobs so much
because it's like his whole thing was
like
it all has to work it all has to work
like for the just a person who hops into
this program with no knowledge of it
they need to do something and it just
works you know and i get like the kind
of mentality it takes and like willpower
to be a person who somehow like
stays the bulldog for that very simple
adage or adage of like it has to work
it's like the same thing with your
making like movies or videos it's like
that shot's out of focus
it can't be out of focus it everything
needs to be perfect yeah like
in like ah i got it it's like is it
perfect well no there's this whole thing
it's like where did i stutter but
somehow you have to be a person
like that pushes and pushes and pushes
and pushes because human beings
we have technical debt if you wanna know
if you wanna this has been isn't meant
to be an insult to all humanity but if
you want to know how humans are just
watch dogs
we're not any different
dogs will let you dogs will do whatever
you let them get away with
and humans are the exact same
yeah why not yeah yeah like i was
watching this show uh tokyo vice i think
it's called on hbo last night and i
was there was a shot in the show where
like you could tell there was like some
gimbal shake and it was like kind of
moving back and forth and it's like
this is like a high budget hbo show and
they just left that in there and then it
just totally takes me out of the show
and now i'm like you know questioning a
whole thing
and that's like that's the technical
debt is like the the little things add
up it's hard it's hard in our in my
personal experience and and uh on the
site and
like i i know how much
scott and the devs
put into
the site like i do not intend to
discredit that in any way
um but sometimes i gotta be that guy
where
i i just got to go well look i know
but this thing doesn't work
so what do we have to do and and you
know we might be off in this other
direction or there might be something
else that we're trying to get done
because of videos coming out or what
have you
but sometimes you just got to stop and
go
okay well let's let's boil this down to
to the functionality of what we need
this to do
and uh you got to keep coming back to it
you get to constantly be coming back to
it because there's no
uh curing technical debt in development
ever
it will always be there no matter
uh no matter what you do but um
yeah sounds like maintenance the thing
is like y'all
there's that line though where
you can't uh
you gotta see the force in the trees or
whatever like with the green screen it's
like all right technical debt a janky
green screen is technical debt yeah deal
with it at some point in the post
production process
so let's build the psych
okay ah there's this little bit here
let's patch it up i know it's gonna
delay things a little bit it's worth it
okay and i gotta adjust the lighting
like this
let's set it up like this it'll pay off
and later but sometimes you get to the
point where it's like
okay if we have to do this next thing we
have to now delay the shoot by a day
yeah and like right exactly is it do you
want to pay the technical debt to the
point where you're not even achieving
right yeah no that's the balance that's
the balance that has a lot of usefulness
yeah it's perfectionism and that's i
mean that's the balance
perfection is the enemy of progress yeah
that's the balance of life yeah
that's the old phrase i mean our whole
mantra is finish it and move on yeah
that's how we get all these videos out
yeah yeah
but yeah it's like okay
uh
we have a green screen and we shoot
three or four hundred shots on it and
then we spend five months doing
post-production because the green screen
was janky or we could have just done a
week of extra prep on the green screen
so that it would have only taken one
month to do these are all hypothetical
eventualities who knows how it'll
actually be hopefully with the effort
we've now put into that green screen the
green screening process should be a lot
quicker well and it's the same thing
with an editing program back to premiere
is like
if
i get to the end of
the process on this episode
and this
specific error errors popping up because
my project's just gotten too big this
timeline's gotten too large
um
that little error
will
like that could cost days because it's
like the whole you lose a day of
progress or whatever like
as those errors pile up
later in the process in these programs
i feel like
the more
i don't know i feel like for premiere
that was always my problem was like the
bigger my project would get the more
like critical errors i would have yeah
and the more errors you have but then
it's also like the more vital it is to
not have an error the bigger project
fits so that reminds me you guys did get
screwed over pretty hard last year by
davinci resolve
yes but i think it was a lack of that
it's certainly something they can fix i
think what you're referring to is that
we have we are using the collaborative
features of resolve so that you know you
can
check off enable for a collaboration on
a project and now we can all work in
real time on a project together which is
like which is insane yeah that's kind of
nuts that's
that's cool to think about which again
premiere
had to some degree
but it's on the cloud so it's kind of
like uh and now i got to be like
i'm gonna be going across the internet i
want to be i can local network i want my
local network you know what yeah what
the the thing i'm remembering was so the
the whole like collaborative process and
how we're like resolve works is that you
have like this server i guess where
all the programs are kind of like
looking at data databases the database
yeah
and that ended up getting white or
something no so what happened let me let
me let me uh like finish what happened
then so like regardless of what that was
it ended up with nick losing two and a
half days of editing and he had to start
over from scratch so let me so what mr
what's your response
what happens is that when you have when
you're not enabled for collaboration
resolve which is amazing feature it live
saves so every mouse click is a save so
you don't have to like premiere i was
just like control s control s like every
five seconds because i was so scared it
was going to crash
resolve has you covered right until you
enable it for collaboration
and we were operating
or i think nick was just learning it at
the time because it was like i hopped in
and then chase hopped in and then we all
started hopping into resolve nick was
learning it so he didn't know that when
it's collaborative you have to
physically save
a or a backup of the project no you
can't life save when it's collaborative
i think you can i think it doesn't now
or maybe they updated it so yeah it
doesn't now which now now it's like not
an issue would that be technical debt if
that was
that if it was it was technical debt
because what happened was nick
accidentally deleted his whole timeline
because if you have in and out set and
you hit delete it'll delete the whole
timeline that's what it was so and then
he freaked out and it like he just
started like
hitting things
and i think it crashed on because
resolve does because there's so much
data
contained in the timeline because the
timeline also has
like data for fusion data for color and
all that it does get a little clunky
when trying to move timelines duplicate
timelines all that stuff so
the program crashed he reopens it
all this entire timeline which
nick you know you got to duplicate
timelines and you got versions and stuff
you know but he so this was his only
timeline of editing and um he lost it
and lost that whole that whole day yeah
it was more than a day
it was like it was two days it might
have been two days here's the thing
though is how many times did that happen
to me in premiere
many times where the project itself is
cursed like i can't do anything with the
project corrupted project files oh man
and that was that error honestly was on
more on us like the the live safe should
be enabled uh enabled during
collaboration which i guess
here's the thing it's like somebody at
davinci who
listened to feedback like okay this
functionality is confusing and it's
being missed and it's costing people
work let's adjust the default moving
forwards let's not just stack another
layer on this or here i'll just hit you
guys with ten more options it's like no
we're gonna change the approach and if
you don't like like that
you're gonna have to update yourself to
meet this new new way we're approaching
it yeah and just like they made the
right decisions though yeah and i think
yeah there was a lot of stuff like that
with resolve where i was frustrated
about it at first of it not being there
because i was used to it in premiere
and then i just
adjusted my mindset and i was like oh
this works way better then yeah because
i was so used to doing it blender's kind
of the same thing for a lot of people
where it's like moving from other
programs into blender it's like oh oh
this is how they do it now
oh i can see this is really fast that's
how unreal engine was for me when i went
over like the way you move around a 3d
viewport and unreal engine versus like
everything else that took me an hour to
get used to yeah yeah but being able to
just fly around here it's like why isn't
every viewport like unreal's viewport in
terms of its controls yeah to be clear
it didn't take me an hour to get used to
the wasd controls of unreal that's a
video game that was instant i like
left click and the right click being it
like left and right and up and down or
left and right and forward and back it
was kind of like a bizarre way of moving
but like after like kind of getting used
i was like okay okay i can see that we
don't touch the keyboard
yeah on every other program it's like
it's like well you might have like left
click right click like alt click it's
like
wait but what if i just left click right
click and then both clicks
and then you your right hand just is
independent of your left hand now
less clicks less keyboard less it's more
efficient it's faster it's the speed of
thought you know yeah yeah no yeah i do
feel like
for me like and i mean these are the
programs i use but like resolve
uh
unreal and blender all
they just feel right like they feel like
simplify a new approach like it's just
it's a simple way of doing it you know
from the ground up because they're
i mean blender's open source
unreal's free
and so is resolved results free so it's
like people
tons of people can just get in on the
ground floor use it give back give
feedback
and they're
i think because they're free and because
they're
so open with people
i think that's the culture there is like
hey like what are the ideas out there
whereas like
adobe's like
hey you want access to our products we
had pay us 52 dollars a month
and that's 70 a month 70 a month or
whatever and it's like it's 70 a month
it's still 52.52 yeah
it's just like
i
i don't like this idea
and this is like
across our economy now where it's like
you don't own anything anymore
you know it's just like you get a ticket
you get a ticket to my attention to
attend your freedom it's like give me
one ver let me buy one version of
premiere
and then you can release the next one in
a few years or something but that's how
it was
forever i know but then they switched to
the sub subscription model and and i'm
not inherently against the subscription
model like i actually find a lot of
usefulness in that i like being able to
just always have the most up-to-date
software at my fingertips like maxon one
for instance
we now have zbrush
we just have it i didn't buy it but we
have it maybe now that be we have it
because it got acquired by maxon and now
if you have maxon one which includes
cinema 4d uh red giant plugins and all
like a bunch of other stuff it's like
you now just have
that and it's the same thing for adobe
and like substance i think they acquired
substance but is that part of the adobe
creative cloud now or do you still have
that separately i don't know but by the
way adobe is
82.50 a month
you can buy it yearly for 55
a month which is really it's 660 bucks a
year they must have us on like uh
we might be paying attention
and the thing is like you can't cancel
your yearly thing you rebuild monthly so
if you're halfway through the year like
i need to stop paying this they're gonna
keep charging you what happens because i
don't have a creative cloud uh
membership anymore but what happens
every now and then is like you know i'll
take a photo and i want to open it in
lightroom or something i'm like oh dang
i gotta
you know
get this like 10 a month one for the
it's like literally just for photoshop
and lightroom i think is 10 or 20 a
month remember when we used to pirate
them
yep way back in the day that's i mean i
i don't know about you guys that's how i
got my start yeah that's how i got my
premiere after i think that's a pretty
shared experience and i think that's
something adobe themselves even kind of
recognize which is why they went to the
subscription model they're trying to
follow the whole steam format of like
you know valve pioneered the idea of
like
pirating isn't a a crime problem it's an
availability problem i i'm butchering
the quote but
but it's like essentially like if you
make a product easy enough to acquire
people will just do that as opposed to
jumping through hoops
you can get it for free easier that's
why that's why i started paying for
spotify yeah yeah because it was so easy
to get who wants to download music
freaking largest music library so
immediately available yeah this kind of
just made it easy it was like before you
had to you literally have to pay you ten
bucks
a month to get access to all the music
pretty much all the music and you know
organize it for me yeah there's been
qualms it wasn't perfect you know but
like
to that that like
that alone like killed
music piracy yeah yeah hey so there's a
bunch of comments in the previous
podcast that said all right if you guys
are don't get on adobe
what should people use let's talk about
alternatives let's talk about free
programs for a second here we just
highlighted how expensive adobe software
is so first and foremost obviously we're
talking about davinci resolve there's a
free version in the studio version so if
those of you out there are wondering
what the paid version has basically it
has noise removal it has support for
higher than i think 4k resolutions
actually you might be able to go higher
than 4k now on the free version free
version does 4k okay i don't think it
does above 4k yeah you can do like 8k
it used to be limited to 1080. that's
right
um
and then there's like a couple other
like higher collaborative the paid one
studio
oh that's right i think the
collaborative server mode uh where you
can all be working off a central
database like you can work on the
central database in the free version but
to have the collaborative mode going i
think you have to pay for that and and
aren't there some other like gpu
features like multi gpus multi gpu i
believe once again that might have
changed
blackmagic design is not really too
interested in
trying to make a bunch of profit off of
davinci resolve at least that's the
impression i get yeah it seems like it's
just hardware that's their main thing
yeah it's it's like um it's like the uh
like microsoft and sony making consoles
is like they want people to buy the
games yeah like the console is just to
get you on those games so it's almost
like because that's another thing about
uh davinci
is the
blackmagic cameras work so nicely in
that program and are like
it's just like this perfect marriage
especially in the color page obviously
because it has access to all the the
data and the camera yeah and they have
like their stream decks they have their
video cards they have their video output
cards there's like a whole bunch of
stuff capture decks
um but but dude you're right if
like when i was
17 years old that was the first time i
started like doing video editing and it
was super basic and i was using like my
dad's copy of like pinnacle studio oh
yeah 17 or whatever
um
but like these days
the software you can literally make
a a feature film quality thing using
nothing but free tools yeah which like
visual effects is an all-encompassing
word
and and for years i only did like 2d
compositing type visual effects i didn't
know how to use a 3d program and the
ones that were available were like 3ds
max mayas and 4d all these super
expensive programs or you had blender
which was like the most complicated
puzzle on the planet
um
that i don't know where i was going with
that basically
blender has gotten very good and it's
free now yeah so blenders it's always
been free it's very good now yeah so
davinci resolve is kind of like i'd say
everybody's go-to for free software for
editing also it has fusion which is a
node based compositor it's it's totally
fine it's great you can use it solid you
can do you can do what you need to do it
has an audio uh like dedicated page for
doing audio mixing it has color grading
it's world classic color grading it is
one of the best programs out there for
color grading it's really used on films
so yeah it's weird to like have an
editor program and you like flip for the
targeting side you're like this is
really really really good why is this
part so good it's like oh yeah it's
because this is the industry standard
starting with that yeah don't forget
about the cut page video page for all
you vloggers out there
um
for all the people that like the
delivery page is like as robust as media
encoder
so then if you wanted to be doing uh 3d
work and even compositing work as well
blender is the next thing that people
should be checking out oh also like
i
before i ever started recommending you
know davinci resolve for a free editing
vfx program
hit film yeah hit film hit film was
great hit film is actually a really good
after effects alternative yeah it's i
mean and premiere alternative like if
you're if you want to stay light with
your program and you don't want to go
super heavy and to like resolve i mean i
i would argue that resolve's not that
heavy but hit film is like a really
familiar feeling premiere in after
effects kind of environment
um there's a free version i'm pretty
sure and there's like a paid version
which isn't that expensive it's not and
and i forget how they do it now but it
was like the paid version i think was
like a couple hundred dollars and that
essentially included a lot more
different like plug-ins and effects yeah
the effects side of things like various
features but like if you just needed to
slap something together real quick maybe
throw some simple effects on and you
didn't really have much time to like
go through your starting find the
password for your adobe account yeah or
whatever to like have to like install it
and all that stuff it's like hit film is
free and it works great yeah and
honestly it's so robust it's like not
just if you're starting out but like
it films yeah he films a great
alternative people definitely check that
out too um
there's blender we talked about resolve
uh
so if you're in photoshop and you're
looking for alternative photoshop
uh there is [ __ ] which is all right what
is [ __ ] [ __ ] is like
source like image editor it's not that
bad i i use it it's it it's got your
basic like you know cut stuff out move
it around put text here shape layers
there there's also i think affinity um
is another software package uh that's a
competitor to
uh photoshop
yeah we should ask griffin
yeah the main thing is there's all these
free tools yeah affinity photo that's
start start with those start with the
free tools utilize those figure out what
you need
based on
what you can get from those free tools
and what you can't get and then make
purchasing decisions for other types of
programs and hardwares based upon that
experience don't just be like oh well
someone told me that i needed to before
i can even shoot a video i need to buy a
camera i need to download adobe suite
and pay for it and i need to buy a pc no
it's like no if you have a smartphone
and like basic access to a laptop you
can
pretty much make any youtube video
that's been made like it's just crazy to
think about between
blender
and davinci resolve
and the
camera phone in your pocket oh yeah you
can make something cause what wasn't
there like an oscar nominated film that
was shot in an iphone with blender and
davinci resolve on your phone you could
make you can make a film as good as any
film up to like 1996.
yeah like straight up like every single
effect shot that includes force gum
it does saving no it's not saving
private ryan uh terminator
um jurassic park yep um citizen kane
and uh i don't know there's a few others
before 96. and then let's say over the
summer you get a job at taco bell you
save your money right you can buy
a
uh the black magic pocket 4k which i
think is like 1200 1200 bucks
yeah like you could put like a red you
could put that stuff on netflix
seriously you buy one black magic pocket
cinema 4k and an 18 to 35 millimeter
lens and you're good yeah i'll do you
one better you get that freaking nifty
50 man man
i had that one
go on ebay it's probably like two
dollars now they're probably
yeah you could probably
using that to prop
life sale for yeah
one
up
his
yeah i mean i've always said invest in
glass before cameras
uh because the glass will last forever
as opposed to your camera getting
outdated and you also don't necessarily
if it's your first camera you don't
necessarily know why glass is important
well yeah and also i've always said that
like
don't invest in a camera at all invest
in a pc invest in a computer because
that's going to be where you spend most
your time totally if you want to shoot
something and you really want to do go
all out make it pro you can literally
rent a red camera for a day for like a
hundred dollars maybe two or three
hundred dollars yeah worst case scenario
and that's
like and then you get like a day or two
rental on on a cinema camera you shoot
your whole thing
and all your money you spent is going
towards the machine that you're going to
spend the next few months editing on
that's true yeah but these days is more
important i i've kind of come around to
feeling like the phone is the thing that
you should invest most your money into
now especially like i mean for for the
stuff that i do with like all the photo
scanning and the the ar real time
tracking and yeah
i think for about a grand total of three
thousand dollars
you could probably have access to all
the hardware and software that you would
need to make some of the most
professional video content in the world
yeah
definitely
and then you'd load up unreal which is
also free and you got
virtual production backgrounds
you could just make the mandalorian for
three thousand dollars
yeah dean's not that far off by the way
it's like that's kind of thing it's like
the money is on you spend the money on
the people so you get a bunch of people
who are focused on doing that like the
hardware these days is not really the
bottleneck i mean freaking
ian hubert made like a hollywood level
ian hubert stuff that's just by himself
yeah it looks so good
it's amazing it is literally better vfx
than a lot of the stuff out there
because it's just he did make a bunch of
gnarly practical sets though that really
true but yeah he is also incredibly
talented yeah that's right ian you're
listening to this right now i know it
um also i want to shout out procreate as
another good software alternative oh i
love procreate wait i wouldn't really
use it as a photoshop thing it depends
what you're using photoshop for
obviously there's painting but even
photo touch-ups
not that bad i've actually used it a
little bit after that um man i'm bummed
i lost all my paintings because i was
doing them all in the procreate beta
poke procreate five beta and then that
beta expired and i can't open it anymore
my paintings yeah no i'm bummed i hadn't
but okay so to to go back to the
question you posed earlier
you are the
senior product design engineer
for after effects and
people are up in arms about
the program they are frustrated and
everyone has a different reason about
why they hate it
and it's your job to kind of like
observe everything and then try to come
up with a reason or a pathway to solving
that yes and
i i can't pretend to know how
what it's like to run
a software company to write code for a
program like that like i don't know how
large the after effects development
doesn't matter here's the thing it
doesn't matter it's like watching movies
it doesn't matter how much you know
about how movies are made the movie's
good or it's bad yes there's no excuses
yeah it doesn't matter how much they
spend on it and like
yeah this shot doesn't matter how many
people set up that they're how hard it
was it doesn't matter
yep yeah i guess yeah no you're you're
completely right i guess what i'm trying
to say is i just don't know like whether
or not my request or any of those
requests are reasonable requests i think
i think the reasonable requests and i
have to have to go after this this is
this me wrapping up my part of the
podcast
the reasonable request is look at what
your program does
what is preventing it from doing that
smoothly and quickly what are the things
that everybody does all the time in your
program and how can you make that faster
don't worry about new features like just
look at how everybody currently uses it
make it faster make it smoother make it
less clicks
make it more stable
that interface
look at what it's supposed to do have it
do the exact same job but literally from
every single pixel redo that interface
and just have everything aimed at its
function like perfectly have everything
run fast everything in real time utilize
100 of my computer's resources i have
talked about no new features at this
point i just simply talked about taking
a program and taking its basic
functionality and actually making it do
its basic functionality
that's it
if i was in charge of it that's the
thing i would do and that's going to
take him probably like i had real life
that would be like a five-year endeavor
right now you know it's like start
working get that pickaxe out let's go
yeah like well yeah i think eventually i
mean i don't know their business model
is so grand now at this point that i
think the the adobe creative suite is
almost
you're probably right you know like
whatever it's one of their it's like oh
yeah
yeah hey adobe so how you guys doing hey
how's the customer service going good
all right keep it up yeah what is the
percentage of the company that's the
creative versus everything they're doing
a whole bunch of other stuff now with
like respect to cloud and
business and yeah so they're
yeah they're international and doing all
this crazy stuff so i don't think that
adobe creative suite is honestly their
biggest thing um
in real market like economics talk
what's probably going to happen is if
they keep going this way eventually
it'll
they'll lose so many subscribers to that
particular
aspect of their business that'll either
become like something that just becomes
a legacy or somebody will break it out
and
fold it into something else and you know
and the market will do its thing with it
and it'll become if people jump ship
yeah you're gonna notice and that's
that's the only solution here is like
for people like
ren to be like i'm not using this
program anymore and then not use the
program and stop paying them i've
already watched a few hours worth of
tutorials on davinci fusion and as more
robust
options become available more and more
people will do that and
you know it's sad but that's kind of how
that's kind of how it works when you're
talking about these huge international
billions and billions of dollar
companies is like
it'll probably get split off and
somebody else will buy it and do
something better with it that's the like
honestly i think the best we can hope
for more people just i mean right now
people are building alternatives and
yeah
yeah you know brick by brick those
buildings aol dude yeah it's still there
seriously like there's like i said that
that autograph project like that program
it's after effects but it's real time
yeah with a real thought interface and
like it's intended to be quick and easy
and yet i still have that same guttural
reaction of i don't recognize that user
interface i don't like it
which i know is
not like the moment i think logically
i'm like oh it's not that different i
can learn this new one that's not a big
deal it's like certainly easier looking
to learn than fusion
it's like why do i have to hit a instead
of v to select i don't want to use this
program
yeah i think there's a uniform
stubbornness to all people when it comes
to trying to learn something new because
learning is hard yep yeah and if you're
a company that makes software like this
you just got to take take the time
like
try to get out there get your users let
them grow with you as you grow together
and as they become
professionals
your software will be the thing that
they use
gosh this was so helpful guys thank you
so much i feel
like
so much better now
you know yeah i feel like jake i know
you had a lot of struggles with that
i've had so many struggles with after
effects i mean there was one time i did
a shot for wren
it was
uh but i ha i do have my ventures in
premiere and and in davinci and
yeah
it's been interesting well i'm excited
to get into some some da vinci i'm going
to like whatever my next project is that
i'm going to have to edit or do vfx for
i'm going to i'm going to try
not to do it you have to you have to
make a rule i will not touch any adobe
products that's the only way you you is
there a video idea here can we do a
video about this let's do it because
it's like i need i need a video project
to exist everybody thank you for
listening to the podcast for me to learn
something i hope you guys had a good
time all right i promise we're done
ranting about adobe products um we're
good now yeah i feel better i can't
believe this took two podcasts to fully
get off our chests
i feel like it's all out there now yeah
yeah uh hey
tell us about your software stories
in the comments below
hey but for real actually all the
comments on the podcast are super cool
to read and yeah like i really like the
discussion and all the comments on last
week's podcast was it was really neat to
see so
it's cool to know that our experiences
echo a lot of other people's experiences
all right thanks for watching everybody
until next time adios